wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
naja ich weiß nicht ich verstehe das
problem nicht worüber redet ihr die
zeitungen in der der artikel über
jahresaktion erscheinen wird die würden
kostenlos nach hause für den laden
drucken das doch super
ich habe die reparatur nicht verkneifen
ja und du kannst jede werbung gut
gebrauchen und so solltest jede
möglichkeit mit der e mail leute in den
laden kriegs nutzen
na ja schon in welcher rubrik würden sie
die annoncen platzieren llanos würde
wahrscheinlich im lokalteil erscheint
sportler besser das entscheide ich nicht
naja wer war es was bedeutet rubrik
rubriken sind teile in der zeitung in
denen es um verschiedene themen geht wie
politik wirtschaft sport kultur tour
nennt man oft fehlt an bis französisch
jedenfalls solltest du das angebot dass
er die gemacht hat unbedingt annehmen
was aus ich entwerfe die noch heute eine
andere sagt und du meldest dich dafür
bei dem reporter einverstanden
vielleicht ist ja wirklich nett immerhin
bis zur single oder